MING: Good afternoon,
my friends.
About right years ago,
Grace joined Google
as a massage therapist.
And when she was
new here, it was
very easy to get on the
calendar, which I did.
So I go on the calendar, and
I took a massage from her,
and she was so good.
And then I kept
going back to her.
And behind her back, I started
calling her Amazing Grace.
And I made one
big mistake, which
is, I started telling
all my friends.
And then after that I couldn't
get on the calendar any more.
So in retrospect, I should have
done one of two things, right?
I should have not
told my friends,
or I should have fewer friends.
Either way, Grace
became very popular.
Good thing is we were
friends since almost day one,
and then we remained friends.
And most of our
conversations were
about spirituality, philosophy,
and important stuff like that.
And then, couple years
back, about two years back,
I met Steve.
Let me see, we were
speaking together
at the World Peace Festival--
World Peace Festival--
in, of all places, Germany.
Sorry.
Those are German?
And so the bad news
is, world peace
did not come out
of that conference.
Yes, we didn't have
world peace after that.
But the good news is,
Steve and I became friends.
And then later on, when I found
out that Steve was American,
he was working in
Germany at the time.
And later on, I found out he
was coming back to the US.
And he was going to set up shop.
He was going to start
the Wellstone Center
in Santa Cruz, where Grace was.
And I was like, these two
people to have to meet,
because together they
can make things happen.
So I got them to meet, and this
came out, among other things.
This came out, the
book that we're
going to talk about today.
The name of the book
is "One Body Massage."
And I'm so glad to have my
friends Steve and Grace here
to talk about this.
And thank you for all
that you do for the world.
And my friends, please
welcome Grace and Steve.
STEVE: Thank you.
I won't bore you for long.
But I just wanted
to let everyone
know, we did start the Wellstone
Center in the Redwoods,
in Santa Cruz, my wife and
I. I'll leave some cards here
if anyone wants to
pick one up afterwards.
But the exciting news
is now that Grace
has finished working on
her book, which is great,
I can't emphasize it enough--
her beautiful artwork, all
the heart and soul she put
into telling her story.
It's not just a practical
guide to massage.
It's really a book about
opening up a new mind
set, a new mentality.
So I think, I'm sure
you'll enjoy it too.
But at some point
soon, she'll also
be doing a weekend workshop
at the Wellstone Center.
So it'll just be
for a few people.
Probably four or six.
And if you're
interested in that,
please let Grace know, or
I'll leave these cards,
someone can approach me.
And that'll be it for me.
So let's just put our
hands together for Grace.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GRACE KU: Well, I have
a confession to make.
I did not grow up
thinking I was going
to save the world, be a
writer, or a massage therapist.
I dreamed of being
a ninja Superman
princess who gets to eat
candy and do art all day long.
I wasn't calm, peaceful,
and oftentimes I
thought everything was about me.
OK, second confession, I
still do that sometimes.
Like most graduates from the
Academy of Art University,
I worked as a web
and graphic designer.
So I'm very familiar
with this, and this.
Oftentimes, I feel like this.
Neck, back, shoulder,
and wrist tension
were part of my identity.
That went on for six-plus years,
until one day I met a stranger.
"I went on a business trip
with Ryan to Venice Beach.
While he worked, I
sat under a palm tree,
sipping a glass of
lemonade, scribbling away
on the sketch pad,
watching a shop owner
making a deal with a tourist
on the tie-dyed t-shirt.
A strange man with two little
white dogs approached me.
The man asked if I could
watch his dogs while he
went to get them some water.
Sure, why not.
I'm on vacation.
I gladly accepted
the responsibility
of watching two cuties.
When the strange man
returned with water,
he introduced himself and
proceeded to share his story.
Larry was his name.
He was in his late 50s and
worked as a clairvoyant energy
healer.
A little strange, I
thought to myself.
Larry began to have visions when
he was seven, seeing or sensing
things that were
not there, feeling
what was about to happen.
He lived with his
single mother who asked
him to keep his gift a secret.
He honored her request
and went on living
like a normal person, until he
had a midlife crisis, at which
point he decided he
was old enough to know
what was best for himself.
So he embraced his
ability to sense and work
with people's energy
to help them heal.
He told me his story
and then offered
to check my energy balance.
The strange man is offering
to do energy work on me,
I thought.
Should I let him?
I looked around.
People were biking
and walking nearby.
I figure, I was safe.
If anything got weird, I
could always yell out, fire!
Plus, I was on vacation.
There was nowhere
I needed to be,
and nothing needed to be done.
OK, sounds good, I tell him.
Larry asked me to sit
comfortably and look out
to the ocean.
First he did some massage
to loosen up my shoulders,
focusing on specific
shoulder joints
with a combination of rubbing,
pulling, and rotating.
Then he reminded me to breathe.
I took some deep breaths
and felt a little bit
more comfortable, like I was
sitting more relaxed and taller
at the same time.
I felt this heat coming out
of his hands on my lower back,
without him actually
touching my back.
I told him I was
five when I pretended
to be Superman,
red cape and all,
and riding my tricycle
as fast as I could.
I took off on top
of the staircase.
Next thing I knew I
was crying for mommy.
Since then, I was always
having issues with my lower
back and my right shoulder.
Larry was concentrating
on moving blocked energy,
as he called it,
from my lower back.
I feel the heat flowing
from my lower back
to the middle of
my back, and slowly
spreading out to my
shoulders and cooling off.
It was a sense of
relief, like finally
letting go of a burden I had
been carrying for a long while.
I sighed and felt like crying.
It was so good to be free
of my emotional baggage.
That was the first
time I experienced
how emotion is intertwined with
the physical body, all thanks
to Larry, a complete stranger
who wanted nothing from me
but half an hour of
my time to heal me.
Thank you, Larry,
wherever you are."
That experience taught
me that not everything
needed to be seen or
measured to be real.
I feel fortunate to
have the opportunity
to explore this
touchy feely world
with the support of my
family, friends, and massage
instructors.
Throughout my career
as a massage therapist,
I'm very blessed to have
so many amazing clients.
Some of you are here today.
Thank you.
I feel like I'm just
going on and on.
OK.
I can feel like my heart
is pumping really fast.
And let me take
a deep breath in,
like I was reminding my clients
during massage sessions,
like breathing deeply into your
belly, and breathe out slowly.
Feel like I'm drawing a blank.
OK.
Let us bring the spotlight
to our nervous system,
because I have, and
you have them too.
So sympathetic
nervous system is also
known as fight, flight,
and freeze response.
Here's the scenario.
Starting your day with a cup
of coffee, checking your email,
then realize your perf
review with your manager
is this morning.
Hurrying getting yourself
and the kids ready,
stuck in the typical
Silicon Valley traffic.
Someone cut you off, did not
let you into the car pool lane.
Finally get the kids
into the daycare center,
then you realize
one baby desperately
needed a diaper change.
Back in your car,
sipping on your coffee,
and all of a sudden, the
traffic came to a complete stop.
You hit the brake
just in time, also
spill that coffee on yourself.
Now you're also late for
your important meeting.
The parasympathetic
nervous system
is responsible for rest
and digest function.
Here's another scenario.
After a spontaneous yoga
and a nourishing meal,
you're lounging
comfortable in your pajama.
You have no appointments
today, so who
cares if your hair looks crazy?
The sun is warm, comfortable.
There's a nice breeze
to keep you feel good.
And you are reading a wonderful
book, "One Body Massage,"
by Grace.
Listening to your favorite music
in the back, you feel good.
Life is good.
When life is easy when smelling
roses, and not so much when
dealing with dirty diapers.
Well, guess what?
Shit happens.
The knee jerk reaction of
getting mad and looking
for who's to blame will
not solve the problem.
Fight, flight, and
freeze reaction
are important for our survival.
However, when it's
working overtime,
it's draining your mental,
emotional, and physical energy.
Then we have a problem.
No wonder today's top
selling prescription drugs
are Lipitor, a cholesterol
lowering drug, 7.2 billion.
Side effects, kidney,
liver and heart failure.
Nexium an anti acid
drug, 6.3 billion.
Side affects, tightness in
chest and vomiting of blood.
OK, I didn't make this up.
Abilify, an anti-psychotic
drug, 4.6 billion.
Side effects, lose
control of muscles.
What would it be
like if we populate
half of the commercial
time and advertising
space with something like this.
This message is brought to you
by your parasympathetic nervous
system.
Hello.
Remember me?
Do you know that deep
and conscious breathing
is a natural painkiller
and stress reducer?
Go ask yourself and give
yourself the permission
to breathe deeply and
consciously any time
when you feel overwhelmed.
And hey, by the way,
there are no side effects.
So should we get some
of that yummy goodness?
You might find it
helpful to have
your eyes closed for this part.
"Feel the warm air
warming up in your nose
and traveling from your
nose, spreading out
to the branches of your lungs.
The diaphragm rises, filling
every organ and blood
vessel with life
giving oxygen. Feel
the expansion of every cell
and sense, and slowly exhale.
The body relaxes.
Any tension that is stored in
the face, between the brows,
around the eyes, in the jaw
line, is starting to let go.
The muscles in the front and
back of the neck lengthen,
creating more space for the
shoulders and the collar bones
to rest.
The arms, elbows,
wrists, and fingers
lengthen as if there is an
invisible light source shooting
out from each fingertip.
The sternum, shoulder
blades, front and back
of the rib cages and belly
muscles come closer together
and squeeze out any
remaining carbon dioxide
and massage the internal organs.
The hips, knees, ankles, and
toes are free of movement.
Cervical, thoracic,
lumbar, sacral,
about all of the 33 of
the spinal vertebrae
are filled with nourishing
cerebral spinal fluid that
travels from the
cranium to the tail bone
and back to the cranium.
The cranial sutures, joints,
tendons, ligaments, muscles,
and blood vessels expand
and contract with the rhythm
of the universe.
Inhalation and exhalation.
Feel the sensation
of the clothes
you are wearing
touching your skin.
Feel the socks on your
feet and inside the shoes.
What's the texture?
Does the sensation change with
inhalation and exhalation?
If you are sitting, notice
which part of your butt
is touching the chair.
Is it toward the back where
you can feel your tail bone?
Is it toward the middle
where you are actually
sitting on your sit bones?
Maybe it's more
toward the front,
where you are hunching over.
Are you sucking in your gut?
Are you breathing fully?
Are your shoulders relaxed,
or are they raised?
Are they pulled toward your
chest, pulled way back,
or happily resting at your side?
Is your neck extend forward?
Is it more comfortable to turn
to one side than the other?
How are you feeling
in your body now?
Feel your feet
rooted on the ground,
and extend to the
center of the earth.
Your arms gently
rest at your side.
Breathe in and draw up the
earth energy from your feet
to your legs and hips.
The spinal discs are
stacking one by one
on top of each other,
with space and fluids
for ease of movement.
Your head is
resting effortlessly
on top of the cervical spine.
It feels like there
is a string connected
to the top of your head,
pulling you toward the sky.
Draw the heaven
energy to your crown,
which is charging
with positive energy.
Breathe out and recycle all
the energy back into the earth
through your feet.
Remember, the body
is three dimensional.
Feel the relationship of your
body with your surroundings.
Feel the air element that
is moving through you,
and wrapping around you.
Feel the earth element
you are standing
on that is holding you.
Feel the water element
you are made of,
and that is flowing through you.
Feel the fire element that
is living beneath the ground
and within your body.
You are made of stardust.
Every element that is in
the universe is within you."
You can gently open your eyes.
Doctor Stephen R. Covey,
author of "7 Habits
of Highly Effective
People," says
that we are not human beings
on a spiritual journey.
We are spiritual beings
on a human journey.
[HUMMING]
I live in the Santa Cruz
mountains with my family,
and every Sunday my
daughter Eureka and I
will roll the trash can down
to highway nine Monday morning
pick up.
And one Sunday, just
like any Sunday,
I pushed the can
down with one hand.
And held her hand with another.
And all of a sudden
she let go of my hand,
she ran in front of
me, and say, stop!
And then she carefully
kneeled down to the ground
and put her hands together
in a prayer position,
and she say Namaste
to the trees.
She say, Mommy, do this.
Like, I feel really silly.
In my head, I was
thinking about, OK.
I should do the dishes, walk
the dog, clean the house,
and cook lunch.
I have no time for this, Eureka.
Then she's like, Mommy, do it.
So I say, OK.
So I kneel down next to her
and looking at the trees.
It's like, wow.
You know, I passed by
these trees so many times,
but I never realized
how beautiful
they are, and the fresh
mountain air, also
the wild flowers that's around
us, and her, right next to me.
At that point I feel so blessed,
and peaceful, and grateful.
My three-year-old
taught me a great lesson
about being present.
Well, let's face it.
It's really not
easy being present.
Therefore, there are
so many books out there
reminding us of it.
Ming.
[LAUGHTER]
Even right now, I'm
sharing my story with you.
But part of my brain is
thinking about something else.
There's another one.
Just all the
thoughts in my head.
Thank you, Ming.
When we are present, we
are one with ourselves.
And through that awareness,
we extend our touch
to another human being.
During lunch with Ming
once, he said to me,
in the center of
our being is joy.
I looked at him like, I'm
not so sure about that.
Just look at all the
miseries in the world.
How could it be?
During my own healing session
from the myofascial release
workshop, I went back in time
and visit my own suffering.
I kicked, screamed,
cried, and one
point I wanted to punch
and bite my therapist.
Well, he gave me
a pillow instead.
It was done in a safe and
supportive environment.
And throughout that, my
instructor, John Barnes,
reminded me that I survived.
I am not what happened to me.
With simple breathing
exercise that
help me to be in the present,
and when I'm present,
I am here.
When I'm here, I
have the capacity
to be touch with my
true essence, which
is love and compassion
towards myself,
love, compassion
towards another.
And that is joy.
Another story to share with you.
"During one massage
session at Google,
I applied acupressure
for an engineer
who was going through
some life changes.
His body was open
to receive the work,
and he felt calm and
peaceful afterward.
However, he was having a hard
time wrapping his mind around
what had just happened.
I think this is a more
engineer perspective,
because he suggested we
should conduct an experiment
to prove the
existence of energy,
and establish what
he felt was real.
Why it never came to my
mind as a massage therapist?
We walked to Charleston Park
next to Google's main campus,
and from a plastic bag,
he pulled out an oven mitt
and a sheet of baking foil.
I brought along a palm
sized clear crystal ball
and rose quartz.
We sat facing each other
on the wooden bench
among well manicured blossoming
cherry trees and tall snake
grass, and then made
waterfall gurgle nearby.
With eyes closed we
rubbed our hands together
to create heat in our palms,
then gradually pulling
our hands apart while
maintaining the unseen
connection.
The engineer opened his eyes
with a look of amazement.
The connection between our
palms was warm, sticky, round,
elastic, fluid, and infinite.
He then put the oven
mitt on his right hand,
and we went back
to concentrating
on the sensation in our hands.
Was there any difference?
For those of you holding your
breath, the answer is no, nada.
The oven mitt did not disturb
the energy flow at all.
Next up, the foil.
My client fashioned
make-shift mittens
out of the foil for each of
his hands, and we tried again.
While facing him and
seeing him with foil hands,
it was hard for me not
to burst out laughing.
The foil made energy feel
cooler, but that was it.
OK.
Now it was my turn to bring
out the crystal and quartz.
I had them in my hands
during this final trial.
The concentration of energy
work heated up the rocks fast,
and the weight in my hands
made me feel more grounded.
But I was not able to
detect the quality change
within the energy itself.
In this one hour
experiment, my client
concluded that
energy does exist,
and can be raised
when we concentrate
and direct our attention,
in this case, to our hands.
For me it was great to witness
how energy follows intention,
and that anyone can
learn to cultivate it."
So now I would like you to stand
up and find a space so it's
big enough for you to open
up your arms without hitting
your neighbors.
Feel free to explore
back of the room.
There might be more
space back there.
All right.
Now we're just going to bounce.
So we're going to start
bouncing from our ankles.
And that's our focus.
Just bounce from our ankles.
Might feel silly at first.
It's OK, we all look silly.
And then move the bouncing to
your knees, up to your hips.
Travel all the way
up to your shoulders.
This is fun.
And to your elbows,
your wrists, open up
the joints, your fingertips.
Finally to your head.
I trust that you
know your limits,
and you know how to
keep yourself safe.
Feel free to make
faces if you like,
if that feels natural to you.
You are free to make sound
if that's authentic to you,
any expression that you have.
And slowly make the movement
smaller, and smaller,
and smaller yet, until finally
you come to a still point.
Now rub your hands together.
Fast or slow, however
that works for you.
Our goal here is to generate
heat between our hands.
Now is a good time to focus
your attention and intention
between your palms.
Remember to breathe.
Remember that's good for you.
Once you feel heat
generate in your palms,
and you can cup your
hands with your hands.
And feel the muscles
around your eyes.
Can they be more relaxed?
Can they be softer?
Where did everybody go?
And now, place one hand
on top of your head,
and the other over your heart.
Let's connect our
mind and our feelings.
Is there something that your
mind wants to tell your heart?
Is there anything
that your heart
wants to share with your mind?
With the mind and heart
awareness, scan your body
and find an achey area.
And now tighten that
achey area or around
it with your intention.
We are going to hold
that for 12 seconds.
And place one hand, or if you
can reach that area with two
hands, you can sandwich that
area, over your achey area
wherever that might be.
We're going to breathe
deeply into that area,
and breathe out completely.
Going to do that six times.
Is this area asking for
nurture and cuddling,
or is this achey area asking
to be stretched and moved?
Now bring your hands in front
of your heart in a prayer
position.
Keep your thumbs
and your pinkies
touched, and open the rest over
your fingertips and your palm
like you're opening up a flower.
Now breathe in the love and
compassion for yourself.
Love and compassion
for those around you.
Love, compassion for your family
and friends, and also those
who have hurt you before.
Slowly place one
hand on your stomach,
and another beneath
your belly button.
Feel the sensation of being
in touch with yourself.
Now place your hand
on top of your head,
and dance on your head.
Wake up your head.
Wake up your mind.
Like a spring mist.
And dance that
finger on your face.
Wake up your face.
Place your hands
on your forehead.
We are going to bring our hands
towards our temporal lobes,
as if though you are opening
up a window in your mind,
and let all the negativity
and worries out.
So move slowly
from your forehead
to your temporal lobes.
When you reach there,
pause, take your time.
Check in with your body.
Are your shoulders
raised close to your ear?
If you are, see if you can
have them slowly drop down.
When you're by your temporal
lobes, now make a circle,
tiny circles there.
And slowly enlarge the circle.
From your temporal
lobes, you are
going to bring your fingers
down towards your chin.
At the same time, you're going
to be opening your mouth.
You might remember this
during our massage session.
So slowly stretch down towards
your chin, and open your mouth.
We carry so much
tension here in our jaw.
If you have your eyes closed,
you can gently open them up.
Look around at people
in this room and smile,
like you have a secret.
Excellent, Feel free to stay
where you are or come back
to your seat.
Whatever that speaks to you.
Forgot to show this earlier.
The present of being in
the now, in the moment.
And the heart and the
mind conversation.
So remember this, energy
follows intention.
Energy, when you
focus your attention
and when you're in the
present, you create energy.
I'd like to share a
little study with you.
"Massage is for all of us.
Everyone can benefit from
loving and caring touch.
Remember the famous
research done
by psychologist Harry
Harlow in the 1960s
on the nature of affection?
He removed baby monkeys
from their biological mother
6 to 12 hours after
birth, and gave them
the choice of two monkey
mommy look alikes.
The first mommy was made of
wire and had a baby bottle
attached to offer food.
The second mommy was
made of soft terrycloth,
but offered no food.
Tough choice.
The experiment showed that the
baby monkey spent more time
with the soft fake mommy with
no food than the wire mommy
with food.
Seeking and offering
affection is innate.
The poetry and magic in touch
begins with self-awareness,
centering, and presence.
Because the real magic is
moving from the heart with love.
Our hands are extensions
of that same love.
After all, nothing
has meaning unless we
put meaning behind it.
And if we do not know
what we mean, what we do,
why bother doing it
in the first place?"
That kind of sounds
like a fortune cookie.
All right.
So here, this shows the
energy when we were bouncing
earlier that helped us unwind.
That was really good exercise
for you to do every day.
And this.
I love this quote
from John Lennon.
"A dream you dream
alone is only a dream,
but the dream we dream
together is reality."
So I took a month off the
summer, went on vacation.
I spent half of the time
at the beautiful Sedona.
That's why we weren't able
to find me [INAUDIBLE].
And the other half I went to
Iowa to visit grandpa Gus.
Well, Gus grew up with his
abusive alcoholic father.
He left home when he was 15.
Gus joined the army and
fought in World War II.
With only elementary
school education,
he managed to make a living
as a hard working farmer.
He raised four children
with grandma Cole.
He is 95 today.
He has survived a knee,
back, and heart surgery.
He's currently recovering
in a nursing home
two blocks away from
his house so grandma can
go visit him three times a day.
When I showed up, grandpa
seemed disoriented
due to all the drugs he was on.
He couldn't hear
very well either.
So we communicate
through smiling, nodding,
and frowning at times.
Well, I wanted to do
something to help him,
so I asked if I could
give him a massage.
He nodded.
So I matched my breath
with his, I gently
placed my hand on his hand, and
wait for his body's permission.
The change is very subtle.
It feels like the muscle tissue
was softer and more open.
It was significant.
So I slowly opened up his palm,
and working between his digits,
and also along his digits.
He was smiling, so I
worked my way up his arms
and repeated the same
thing on the other side.
Well, this man has never
ever had a massage before,
so he was looking
at his own hand.
And then he put his
hands like this.
He said, I'm ready
to go boxing now.
The next day I went back, I gave
him shoulder and back massage.
And I said, hey, can
I work on your neck?
So I had him laying down.
I sat behind him, cradled
his head in my hands.
I could feel his blood's
circulation, his breathing
cycle, and also
his cranium rhythm.
Oh.
And I also felt his sadness,
confusion, and fear.
So without words I told
him that he is loved.
At that moment, grandpa
transformed into a little boy.
We connected deeply and
meaningfully without words.
Right before I have
to go fly back home,
I went back to visit him again.
I was sad because I wasn't
sure if it was goodbye for now,
or goodbye forever.
Grandpa touched my hand,
and look at me with clarity.
He said to me, I will be OK.
"Love and compassion are
necessities, not luxuries.
Without them, humanity
cannot survive."
Dalai Lama.
I'd like to close this
story with a mantra that
come to me during a
walk in the moonlight.
[SINGING] May the light shine
on you, the warm light of love.
May the light shine through you.
The bright light of joy.
May the light be with you.
The pure light of peace
for you are the light.
I'd like to give thanks
to Ming and Steve
for their contributions
to "One Body Massage."
To my massage instructors
and colleagues
contribute their knowledge,
Rock is here today.
Thank you, Rock.
And special friends
that helped me to fund
this book in the beginning.
Also for your presence,
thank you so much.
I believe we have
some time for Q&A.
AUDIENCE: So, yeah,
my name is Gopi,
and I work with Grace in a
completely different capacity,
and always been struck
by how much you bring
this aspect of everything
that he spoke about,
and even things he learned
from the world of healing
in massage therapy,
into your other work,
into the Google
work you do with me.
And so I wanted to
comment on that.
And then I had a
question, because I
would like to embody that.
And so the wisdom taken
from these traditions
actually show up in
my business meetings,
or in my product
development work.
How do you do that,
is the question.
Or what is the best way?
GRACE KU: What's the best way?
Well, I would just
use my own experience
while I was working as the
web and graphic designer
constantly dealing
with deadlines.
I think communication is
really a difficult thing,
because a lot of times
we have expectations.
So it's good to give
empathy to another person.
Doesn't mean we have to
agree, but to take the time
and give the other person
a space, to really hear
them and see what
are their needs,
even been with a client,
exactly what they want.
What they want, is it
something possible?
Is it reasonable?
Is it something that
we can deliver and come
to a peaceful solution?
I think that would be a good
way to deal with business.
Especially, I manage
Gopi's schedule.
I know how busy he is.
And a lot of you guys are, too.
Like constantly meetings,
and running here to there.
Deadlines, projects, and
can be very, very stressful.
So I feel that if any
time when you feel
stressed, take a deep
breath in, and know
that everything is fine.
Because everything is.
We are here, we
are enjoying life,
we are being here itself
is a gift, to be who we are
and embrace that.
And I think when you walk
into a room with that people,
that energy transform from
you to another person.
And I think we can
all smile more.
When we smile, we create
these natural endorphins.
And people look at you.
It's like, oh, she's
smiling, and she's happy.
I'm not afraid to come
talk to her or him.
So I hope that
answered your question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Quick comment.
So, yeah, like Ming, I've
known Grace for probably
over eight years, back when I
was based in the Tokyo office.
And I came out.
I was with Google for
about two years then,
and I had never had
a Google massage.
Or actually really any massage.
And I think just kind by
accident, I found Grace.
I had a massage.
And it was so amazing that I
also called her Amazing Grace
behind her back.
And I always look forward to
coming back and seeing her.
I remember I used to
email you and be like,
Grace, I'm going
to be in town for,
you know, in July, it's
like three months out.
Any time, any chance I
can get an appointment?
And I don't know if that was
before [INAUDIBLE] existed
or if I just didn't
know how to use it.
But I used to always
email you and be like,
try to get on your schedule.
And now, again, too
I've, told all my friends
and now it's tough to
get an appointment.
But I do want to, I
just want to thank you
for always being there
to sort of heal me,
you know heal, for your
healing, both body and mind.
There are times Grace
knows I come and see her,
and she says, how
are you doing today?
And I'm like, oh, my
shoulder is killing me.
Oh, please just fix my shoulder.
Now it's hip, or
now it's my ankle.
It's always something.
And other times I walk in,
I just walk in, big exhale
and go, it's been a
tough couple of weeks.
I just want to relax and fade
off into the Grace's world.
So thank you for always
providing that escape.
GRACE KU: It's our world,
because we dream it together,
remember?
AUDIENCE: That's true.
So thank you.
GRACE KU: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So you've
put a lot of yourself
into this book with
the stories you
shared, and also
all your lessons.
And I'm wondering, in getting
in touch with yourself
while writing this book, which
you did every day, while you're
riding the bus over to
get from Santa Cruz.
What did you learn along
that way on that journey
of writing that book?
GRACE KU: Hm.
I learned that
it's so much harder
to put feeling into words.
Because when I'm in the massage
room, I'm with a client,
it was very intuitive
for me every time.
I don't think about, I
don't have a session plan,
because I feel
session plan is-- it
doesn't work for a real person.
Every time you come to see
me you're a different person.
You feel differently.
So when someone come to
me, I just do what I do.
I let my hands do what they do.
So put that into words was
really challenging for me,
for sure.
Something I just do it,
have to put into words?
Like oh, OK, let's
break this down.
How do I do this and that?
That was challenging.
And sometimes I'm on the bus,
I can write a whole chapter.
And sometimes I sit there for
an hour, I only wrote two words.
So it fluctuates.
And I take my own
advice on the bus.
Not this, the sit up,
sit on my sit bones,
and breathe any time I
feel like I'm freaking out.
I go, OK, just breathe.
When Steve emailed me, say
OK, we need this chapter
by the end of this week.
There are four things I
do with my three-year-old.
We say this.
We say, breathe, slow down,
don't freak out, and Namaste.
Those are the four mantras
I do with her every day
when I take her to daycare.
So that's also a reminder for
myself, when I do freak out,
or when I'm not breathing.
AUDIENCE: Was there anything
you learned about yourself
from the introspection
along the way as well?
GRACE KU: Oh, I learned a lot.
AUDIENCE: That you're
willing to share?
GRACE KU: I learned
that oftentimes,
when we give people advice, it's
something that we need mostly.
It seems like it's the
universe's way to remind us.
OK, I feel universe's
way to remind
me to not take
everything personally,
because I tend to do that.
Or to please everyone.
All right.
So be true to yourself.
I think that's most important.
And you attract the right
people into your life,
and the right kind
of work, and people
who naturally resonate with
your work will come to you.
I don't need to pretend to
be somebody else I'm not.
So that's what I
learned, mostly.
AUDIENCE: I just have a
little question, which
I don't know if you
have an answer to,
but I'm wondering about
Larry, on the beach in Venice.
GRACE KU: Oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: Was there
ever any other-- did you
hear anything about him?
Did you ever seen him again?
GRACE KU: No.
AUDIENCE: Have you thought
bringing the book down
and trying to find him?
GRACE KU: No.
I think maybe he
might be a ghost.
Or spirit from the future
that travels through time
and come to me, say, Grace,
I have a lesson for you.
So no, I don't know
anything about this guy.
Just a nice person,
wanted to help me.
AUDIENCE: With his dogs
on the beach in Venice.
GRACE KU: Yeah.
So if you go to Venice Beach,
remember to look out for Larry
with two dogs.
You might get a free
massage session.
Well, thank you so much for
spending the time with me
this afternoon.
I appreciate it.
MING: The book is
"One Body Massage,"
available where books are sold.
And my friends, our
very own Grace Ku.
Thank you.
GRACE KU: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]